they're gonna be able to at the bomb
plant and happy even waiting for the
push in fall and get the spray shot
anyway what is what effect and well I
mean it works out it falls going to his
thick head not like that on one boob is
what oh wow that was boss pullin that
was so down quick ballin playing at a
very Ariel heat so the cement right
behind him can put up a smoke but they
might shrunk through it India not the
team to slow down and he's going to look
for the opening right around the corner
flashbang goes in and follows the first
shot goes for the final team are going
up on that mpk as well now water shot he
just takes off all the place better
graduation I think that was an Aston
footsteps now it's worked perfectly
oh definitely the full arms like they
have no idea actually just now they
might realize again while there's the
angle and Paula mentioned make it out
we've got the kit as well this all comes
down to who is actually going to peak
first there's that it says fun headaches
going down and fall in lost man left he
finally stopped audience and get the
second shot Susan he's bringing it back
it's now a 1vs1 and he's looking for
flame ease in that corner fallen coming
up with the artillery and it's got to be
a triple kill fallen picked up the slack
with that AWP it's on now burns very
very low Falls got to do some work self
has good positioning over towards drop
it Lance that shots into boxes they get
the kill that's the bomb that forces out
felt fall under to be save this AWP got
to goes for a shot that smart does get
Kaddu jumps up Gill a bit of time on
this is good be a ten-second abused he's
gotta hit the shot right now
disadvantage here that Otto's fights are
still wrecking them from flame Ian's
falling trying to move close here midair
shot on Guardian he tries again he still
got a little to help left jumps around
solid it gets that shortened LC you know
one-on-one and falling you could tell he
wants to carry your team back here we
already lost the post around it over
time please making his way around the
Train
trying to see if you can maybe catch out
fallen not got the hell for it fall
after the shot immediately he's trying
to predict it see you fold it off after
shots take up all three kills have been
struggling with this more aggressive
style towards the a sight off the pot
around that's a finally going to change
it up a bit however pimp is immediately
shut down by fallen literally just goes
directly for the peak again as a player
being caught apart looking for a
controlling Russian they come out or
there we go this packs come down and
that's going to be over here few shots
with no kill coming out Kerrigan drops
him and boredom because back on takes a
second his own understood that's going
to be the great service so the fourth
what are you doing still the man
advantage here for NIV and fallen if
ever there was a time for you to come
alive it is now picks up the first kill
gets the second this is what this red
dot a third one and it's going to be on
cut right don't have another flashing
allowed me to through it and falls
behind him as follows it's like hey guys
don't find me looking for the shot he's
going to get it the two kills for him on
that backstab even looking for the
apartments a headshot on Kenny just
obliterates him now it's going to be in
became happy to last you live here
forever BK gets caught out in the open
there it is Point Blank gets Lee a I'm
believing a bit of a believer would you
suggest that you don't want to stop
believing it's one you can surround okay
packs up one oh stop it to believe as
well Henry cuz he's gonna take it
my barn Blainey Edward blame me again
finding three killed it's now done it's
bowling top and hold on to this fallen
grabbing one one more coming as there's
a second pickup from fallen he does get
flat so we have to hide the corner in
the bomb from Nobby now going to move
out onto the Avon site still no presence
here they are boxed in and they've got
to hold it this is the Alamo for LG
holding back out over here inside 13 HP
but fallen testing the waters here he's
going to grab see if he still has a
chance to do this guarding those in C
behind him and fall and grab Guardian as
well he has to save this fourth team
flaming up pressing for common is going
to be able to collect out a boys from
him thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button